bonjour j'ai un bachelier bonjour
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines
nous sommes au dixième jour de
confinement la situation économique est
à quasiment à l'arrêt pouvez vous nous
décrire la situation économique globale
dans les yvelines
à partir des témoignages que vous avez
des chefs d'entreprise la situation est
plutôt préoccupante actuellement vous
savez que les yvelines c'est un
département qui est industriel donc il
ya deux filières importante l'automobile
et l'aéronautique et l'automobile est à
l'arrêt puisque les deux usines de
poissy et de plats sont à l'arrêt donc
du coup tous les sous traitants aussi
ont des difficultés peut justement pour
avoir une activité donc l'activité des
sous traitants et l'état 50% à peu près
pour l'aéronautique les faits pas encore
sensible mais il le sera par la suite
puisque les commandes d'avions se
diminue actuellement et donc il y aura
certainement un effet sensible donc 75%
de l'activité donc industrielle dans les
yvelines est arrêté donc est à l'arrêt
ce qui est beaucoup
il ya aussi un domaine qui est qu'il ya
eu qu'à stopper nettement c'est le
tourisme activités touristiques s'est
arrêtée complètement presque
complètement puisque 90% de l'activité
touristique est à l'arrêt actuellement
et au niveau touristique a beaucoup de
sous-traitants à qui dépendent de
l'activité touristique
il ya beaucoup de lieux justement
touristiques qui sont aussi utilisés
pour des événements les événements qui
n'ont pas lieu ou qui n'auront pas lieu
qui sont reportés et donc l'événementiel
aussi touchés donc qu'est d'événementiel
et toucher le btp bien sûr et touché
également la logistique est également
été touchées donc il ya beaucoup
d'activités bien sûr bien sûr
l'hôtellerie-restauration et le commerce
qui avait déjà eu à gérer des baisses
sensibles des derniers mois avant la
crise sanitaire
avez vous des chiffres sur le nombre de
commerces qui ont dû fermer passe
le gouvernement leur demandes et 55 %
des commerces endurant dû fermer dans
les yvelines ce qui représente donc à
8000 8000 entreprises 40 mille salariés
et puis un certain nombre de commerces
qui n'avait pas l'obligation de fermer
ont quand même fermé par que soyez
manqué de salariés soit pour des
problèmes sanitaires ils n'ont pas voulu
ouvrir donc en particulier les grandes
surfaces de bricolage certaines grandes
surfaces de bricolage n'ont pas ouvert
les garages sont ouverts un quart des
garages seulement sont ouverts donc vous
voyez que non seulement il y a ceux qui
ont été obligés de fermer mais ceux qui
ont fermé malgré tout et puis dont 75%
du coût de l'activité des commerces à
baisser dans les yvelines et la
fermeture des marchés va pas arranger
les choses à pour les artisans dans le
domaine justement d'alimentation et des
produits de bouche
est ce que vous êtes optimiste sur
l'avenir est ce que les entreprises vont
fermer
est-ce qu'il ya déjà des dépôts de bilan
est ce que vous êtes plutôt optimiste
pessimiste il ya entre les deux je
dirais que la crise est quand même
importante et des entreprises était déjà
fragile avant ces crises sanitaires donc
il est évident qu'elle sert nombre
d'entreprises dans disparaître ça c'est
inévitable simplement nous devons
essayer toutes les partenaires qui
aident les entreprises justement essayer
de les aider à passer cette crise les
dispositifs qui ont été mises en place
par à la fois l'état et la région sont
quand même important moi je conseille
aux entreprises de les utiliser lors
qu'ils rentrent dans les critères et
aussi d'utiliser les prêts bancaires qui
permettent justement de passer cette
phase de trésorerie éventuellement
difficile ça devrait leur permettre
justement de passer 6 mois 9 mois
hélas après la crise est là que les la
situation va être la plus grave
justement et c'est là qu'on doit
apporter le maximum d'informations et
des aides aux entreprises du territoire